a leopard with four heads and a lion
with eagle's wings and and then there's
this woman who's surrounded by the stars
and the moon and the sun. It sounds like
all like crazy symbolism that we can
find in Danny Revelation and some people
for that reason don't even want to look
into it, right? But we've got Cameron
with us today. So you've used media,
art, all the concepts together. You're
even working on a show to explain Daniel
and Revelation for everybody to
understand. And so your ministry is
called what?
>> Rebrand Prophecy.
>> Rebrand Prophecy. And so can you give us
a brief overview of what you're doing
with that and the show before we kind of
dive into some of the art you've
created?
>> Sure. Yeah, absolutely. So the idea of
rebrand prophecies essentially like you
said, many people are very confused by
Bible prophecy, are intimidated to even
dive into Daniel and Revelation. And uh
I was kind of in the same boat 6 years
ago just before starting uh Rebrand
Prophecy. God used some people to kind
of blow my mind this one day when all of
these weird elements clicked together.
And suddenly I saw Bible prophecy not as
a list of timelines and dates and beasts
but as a story.
>> And it's a story centered around a God,
a father who's willing to sacrifice
everything to reunite with his children.
And so from that day, we we decided,
okay, we want to use art and
storytelling to present Bible prophecy
as a story and make it easy for anyone
to to to dive into it. And so that's
kind of what this illustration does and
what the show uh will do is take the
messages of Daniel and Revelation to a
much larger audience
>> through an animated show.
>> I love this because Revelation is so
visual. I mean, that was very
intentional with God's, you know, like
he wanted us to see it in the pictorial
picture of it,
>> right?
>> And and it's funny to me, this came up
in the last show, that people go, "Oh,
it's such a scary book. I don't want
this." But how many movies talk about
the end of the world and have weird
beasts and stuff like that? Like Marvel
Everything, right? But you're going to
go watch that, but not this. Like,
>> you know, this is this is real life,
like what's going on behind the scenes.
And I think it's awesome. I also wonder
if God knew, you know, kind of
foreshadowing, hey, at the end time,
you're going to have all this media
everywhere, like you said, like movies
that flash in your face and and pictures
and magazines and all these different
things and we're used to, you know, uh
going through Tik Tok,
>> but that God understands that and he's
like, I'm going to give you this, like
you said, like this visual idea and and
I personally think studying and
revelation is so fun because it's like I
have to go on this excursion to like
decode this and decode that using
scripture because scripture explains
itself in other parts like hey you can
use other parts of scripture to decode
and understand Daniel revelation it's
like a big puzzle I think it's awesome
>> verse three would not tell you you know
blessed is you who understands that came
up in the last conversation too and it's
like yeah like why would John have
written that for you not to understand
this book
>> yeah verse one says it's the revelation
of Jesus Christ so I think it's just as
much of the gospel as the gospels itself
like you were saying it's the story of
Jesus It's a love story,
>> which then it makes it way less scary.
>> He's trying to win back his bride.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know, his bride's getting chased
by some big old dragon person. That's
Mario, right?
>> Well, Mario might have gotten it from,
you know,
>> of course.
>> Yeah. Anyway, so so tell us more a
little bit about your show that you're
trying to work on.
>> Yeah. So that's actually what started
Rebranded Prophecy was the show cuz as
soon as I kind of got this epiphany, I
was like, we need to make some sort of
animated show. um it just made the most
sense with animation. Animation is
interpretive art rather than live action
is
>> representative art. And so you have much
more uh ability to explore more abstract
kind of surreal topics like Bible
prophecy with animation. And so
originally I thought it was going to be
kind of a YouTube series of like
15minute videos more of a Bible project
style like illustrations with narration
over the top. But as we kept developing
it, it started to turn into something
much larger. And so now it's a um it's
gone through a lot of stages. Um what it
now is with the the most recent rewrite,
it's a two season. Each season has seven
episodes. Um 50 minutes, 50- so standard
television length. uh and each episode
pushes the larger biblical narrative
forwards while focusing on a single
character.
>> So the first one kind of sets up the
rebellion in heaven. The second one
follows Adam
>> 300 years into the antidolivian world.
>> So we kind of explore the the the guilt
that he has to deal with and the story
of the fall of humanity. And then it
kind of goes on through like that,
skipping centuries to focus on a single
character while pushing the bigger story
in the background forwards. So we go
through all of Daniel and Revelation all
the way to the to the new earth.
>> Wow. Um
>> that's cool. And all animated.
>> All animated.
>> Wow. That's what kind of animation.
>> So the kind of new generation style of
animation. We're kind of in the in the
the heft of the wave of new animation,
which is kind of your arcane
um Spider-Verse
>> um Last Wish K-pop Demon Hunters and
>> Right. And it's it's this um style that
focuses more on dialing in your look in
the visual development phase and then
>> embrace the world,
>> embracing it and and spending crazy
amounts of ingenuity to figure out how
to make that look come alive on the
screen in 3D.
>> So, it's a 2.5D style. Has that kind of
very painterly aesthetic.
>> Cool. Um, and but it's not like like the
shows, some of the things I just
mentioned, they have more realistic
proportions. So Nebuchadnezzar isn't
cute, chubby cheek Nebuchadnezzar,
>> in other words.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, so that's that's kind of the the
animation style, uh, which is getting
cheaper,
um,
but is still going to cost a lot.
>> Uh, so we're we're just developing right
now, finishing up the pilot episode.
We're going to run the Kickstarter for
that. Uh, and then with the pilot and
our pitch deck and our show Bible, move
into more of an investment system to
make season one. That's the plan at the
moment, but we're, you know, letting God
lead and see what happens.
>> So awesome. Like I think that there's
just need for this. I know as we're
coming in the end of the world, there's
a lot of decisions that need to get
made.
>> I think that's why the Bible describes
it as a loud cry. I feel like we're
seeing a loud cry get louder. And it's
like more voices are being added
constantly and you see this dovetailing
crossover of like the end is coming and
this is why you need to know this and
this is why this is important to
understand because for you to make a
decision on which side of the fence do
you stand on you have to have the
information.
>> Yep. Absolutely.
>> So I think that that the book of
Revelation people people have have
skipped over it, lost track of it and
everything. But um when we talked about
this in the in one of the previous
episodes um I you know all of these
things that are brought up here it's
like almost a culmination of all the
things that have been happening from the
beginning. Yes. So, I like what you're
doing with starting at the very
beginning, understanding where all the
steps are taking you because if you can
understand the big picture and take a
step back, then you're like, okay,
>> there's a time coming that I have to
make my stand,
>> right?
>> And and and I think like, you know, how
many movies have done this? I've heard
him say it in X-Men, take a stand. The
end of the world is coming. I've heard
him say it in Marvel, take a stand. Know
what side you're going to be on, right?
So the world is preparing to make a
stand
>> and I think we to stand on God's side
>> you know revelation is an important
book.
>> Yeah. In order to know like or or to be
trained to be in what side you need to
stand is like you need to study this you
need to understand for yourself. But I
like you brought this graphic um over
and this is something that you also you
know people can order it as art for
their home or print it really big right
to hang it up somewhere. Um, but can you
tell us what is this exactly? And I kind
of because I know you've I've seen this
before. You kind of walk through the
entire story of redemption almost of the
Bible of Jesus coming from from the
beginning of Satan's fall all the way to
the end of the second coming and
everything in between. So, can you walk
us through that?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So, this basically um
my brother got this idea about two and a
half years ago. We were just making a a
booth exhibit for a conference. Um we
didn't have the show, you know, the show
isn't out yet. And so we wanted
something that would grab people's
attention, start conversations, and he
was like, "What if we put all of Daniel
and Revelation into this epic visual
that you could look at for hours because
it has all this detail?" And so
>> we um worked over the next three months
and got a line work edition done. And
then uh I think about a year ago we
finished the full color edition and then
about 3 months ago we finished a detail
pass because this place ordered it 24T
and so we had to add even more detail.
Um so essentially
it tells the entire story
of the the battle between the kingdom of
heaven and the kingdom of man. And this
is what a lot of people when they look
at Bible prophecy, as we were
mentioning, they just see the beasts.
And Bible prophecy isn't really even
about the beasts. It only brings them up
to tell us that all of these human
kingdoms, all these human systems will
never be able to fix the brokenness of
society.
>> Uh and so that's why the cross is at the
center here where um
>> it's a revelation of Jesus.
>> It's a revelation of Jesus. It doesn't
say it's a re it's a revelation and an
uncovering of the the dragon.
>> You know what I mean? And and it's like
culminates in this this end where it
talks about where the war began all the
way to the end. And then it's like
here's how it's going to play out and be
ended and and God's making a promise.
How many thou 2,000 years ago that this
was written, right? This is what's going
to happen. It'd be impossible for you to
guess that. Impossible.
>> Right. 100%. It gives huge credibility
to God's word.
>> And I I think this is so what what's so
interesting about Bible prophecy. Most
people focus on the prediction of human
kingdoms. Bible prophecy also predicts
the establishment of the kingdom of
heaven.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh it says unto 2,300 days then shall
the sanctuary be cleansed. Our bodies
are sanctuaries. Mhm.
>> And so that means that in the time of
the end, there is this
>> group of people who fully reflect the
character of God.
>> Here's the patience of the saints that
have not spot nor a wrinkle. You know,
>> Jesus said, "My kingdom is not of this
world. It is within you."
>> So the kingdom of heaven is simply
the spirit of Christ living in the
hearts of a group of people.
>> And I think this is an important point
because, you know, a lot of people,
they're looking for some sort of
exterior thing to happen, right? They're
looking to the Middle East. What's going
on over there? You got a lot of
Christianom that's trying to pay
attention to Israel and all this kind of
stuff and like, hey, this is this is
this is great for us to understand and
know what what the world powers are, but
it takes away from what this focus is.
And that's God changing our hearts.
Exactly.
>> That's why he's knocking on the door of
our hearts. The biggest problem that we
have, I believe, as God's followers is
open the door.
>> Like like it's it's not so much
something that's going on all around out
here as much to say. And it's like
sometimes when you get too focused on
all those things, it you you lose the
focus of like God wants to solve the
problem in our own selves.
>> 100%. Yeah. Absolutely. Um I think so
I'll give you just a really quick
rundown of what's in here.
>> I love this.
>> We start here with the war in heaven.
>> Um we have the angels falling from
heaven.
>> Oh, cool. Yeah. Dragon.
>> It's both represented symbolically with
the tale of the dragon taking a third of
the stars of heaven and literally come
to earth.
>> Uh, and then we have the Garden of Eden
here with the fall of man.
>> Can I make a comment right here about
this? Go ahead. Um, go back up to the
stars and the dragon. Okay.
>> Just for people who have known our
channel, we talk about Hollywood a lot.
I think it's very ironic that we in our
culture, we have these things called
stars.
>> Yeah. The Hollywood Walk of Fame.
>> And it's like the only time that the
Bible references the stars in this kind
of scene. It's talking about the fallen
angels.
>> Yeah.
>> Just think that's kind of interesting.
Well, there's some other references to
stars, too. But but yeah, but I see your
point that that really it's
>> when you think about Hollywood stars and
it's about worshiping these people
>> and then it's an interesting point that
yeah, like that at one point there was a
false worship happening in heaven when
all of this started
>> of Satan
>> wanting to have worship for himself and
then the fallen angels worshiping Satan
over God and they fell. And Hollywood
plays on these themes. If you remember
from the Truman show, the light that
fell from the ceiling was called Sirius
9th Canis, which is which is the
brightest star in the ninth Canis
constellation. And it was a falling
star. And that's what like woke him up.
It was like, you know, so they they they
touch on a lot of these things, but I
just wanted to point that out cuz it's
like, you know, for everybody that
thinks this is super scary, you've
probably seen this in Hollywood.
You know, at least be consistent. If you
think this is scary and you want to
avoid this, avoid the Hollywood stuff.
And then just to mention that too, um
I'm currently editing a video uh
exposing Shrek the whole series.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Wait till you see this thing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, so this probably would
have dropped already when this video has
dropped, so we can put a link in the
description. But yeah, the dragon the
dragon appears in there, too. And uh I
won't um you know, give any any hints
about what it's referring to. You can
have to watch the Shrek video. But it's
it's everywhere. It really is. And the
bride is in Shrek. um the Jesus, the the
stars, the moon and stars around the
woman, Jesus, everything.
>> Yeah, it's wild when you see those
elements.
>> Yeah. No, that's that's very true. Um in
fact, that kind of reminds me
>> the common thread that you see through
this entire illustration is this
contrast between, like I said, the
kingdom of heaven, the kingdom of man,
or the flesh and the spirit, or
>> uh fear versus love. Mhm.
>> Um
and and we we even see this here at at
you know with Satan's deception. He's
basically saying you don't need the
spirit of Christ, right? He's like, when
have you done anything wrong? You know,
>> none none of the angels had ever done
anything wrong. So, it was very easy for
them to think, maybe I'm good
>> in and of myself, right? Maybe I don't
need the spirit of God. Maybe the flesh
is good. Right? It wasn't the same
as as far as flesh and humanity, but it
was it was still this decision between
>> should I trust God and his spirit or
should I lean on my own understanding?
>> Yeah.
>> And then we see that same thing in the
garden.
>> That's so true.
>> Uh Lucifer, you know, as in the form of
of of a serpent, he says,
>> "God's told you this, but he's keeping
you from the potential you could have if
you go outside of his will." Mhm.
>> And that's what we see in narcissism all
the time, which also happens in movies.
>> It is the pattern that we we've we've
kind of recognized. And when you see it
like that, then it's like, man, when so
many movies, so many different
production companies, I mean, you're
talking thousands of people, writers,
all I mean, how would you have that kind
of consistency? That's impossible.
>> And so, it's like I I I feel like
there's a golden thread through God's
work.
>> There's also a golden thread through
Satan's work.
>> Yeah. the idea of nosis, you know, like
the snake. You know about gnosticism a
little bit like what what
>> um I'm less familiar with it than
agnosticism ornosticism. Yeah, give me a
>> So, so it's basically like the second in
the second centuryish. There was some
people claim it was an offshoot from
Christianity. Some other scholars claim
it was actually like a standalone
religion that just had some Christian
elements to it. But basically, it start
flipping the Bible story upside down. So
what you have here it basically flips it
right and it's like okay now Satan is
actually good. So the snake in the
garden of Eden came to bring you nosis
meaning enlightenment and he actually
knowledge. Yeah. He he actually wants to
help you and he's your friend and Jesus
is actually the evil character which is
like a a theme we see throughout the the
movie industry. Um which again really
fits into this bigger picture that
you're showing us here of this battle
between good and evil and who will you
worship in the end. And it started with
Adam and Eve like you're explaining.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. And and what's
interesting is Lucifer the snake, he's
offering them this chance to be like
God.
>> Now, of course, they were already made
in the image of God.
>> Already made like God.
>> So, they're already doubting that maybe
maybe,
>> you know, God is keeping something from
me. Maybe I'm not as much like him as he
said I was. Right.
>> And what's interesting, the thread
through Bible prophecy is that when
humans try to play God, they become
beasts.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, wow. That's exactly
>> that's what we find in all of these
kingdoms. God uses these beasts to
represent human power
>> trying to fix society, but it won't fix
it.
>> Human systems can only conform people's
actions through fear and coercion
>> until it gets to the point where it
becomes so forceful and then it falls
apart. Like Revelation 14, Babylon is
fallen is fallen. You know, it's like
the the system that's set up from the
man's, you know, position, a war against
God is falling apart.
>> Right. Right.
>> Are you using the red around the tree to
tie in the red from the dragon?
>> Sure. Yeah. I I didn't think about that
specifically, but we knew that we wanted
the tree to signify a sense of danger,
but also a lure. And so that's why the
fruit is blue. because we have the red
which is kind of this danger but the
blue uh is a very kind of alluring
tantalizing kind of magical feel.
>> It also has has a bit of a a matrix
maybe red and blue pill.
>> No, I'm just kidding.
>> It's funny.
>> And and so here Yeah, you do have like
cold and warmth. You have kind of with
the tree of life this warm homey
feeling. Um but yeah, you're right. The
the the the serpent, the dragon does
have that redness to it. And we actually
did think about this because you'll
notice the wine of Babylon pours into
the water.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> Wherever the wine of Babylon is pouring
into the water, the water is stormy.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> There's a verse in Isaiah that says,
"The wicked are like a troubled sea."
>> And that troubled spirit, well, the wine
of Babylon represents this clamoring,
selfish spirit trying to get above other
people, right? You're willing to stomp
on other people to get to the top. Now,
if you have a bunch of people stomping
on each other to try to get to the top,
you're going to have tumultuous waters,
right? And so, you have all these
people, you notice the sea, and then it
becomes people running up these mounds.
The kingdoms are not on flat ground.
They're on these mounds that people have
to run up to to get to the top.
>> Mhm.
>> Because every kingdom, every
governmental system promises to create
utopia. That's why
>> Satan's system looks like a pyramid.
>> Yes.
>> Pyramid scheme.
>> Yeah. It's all climbing a ladder and
it's all trying to be the top dog. If
you if you try to understand what the
world really pushes is to just be the
best. And when they are so focused on
the goal, so not the process, the goal,
right? You're going to do some pretty
awful things. Harvard actually did a
study that was that was um trying to
understand like u businesses that that
would make uh task orientated like goals
as your measurable thing for you to do.
And they found that when that was the
the actual goal of the company, people
would lie, cheat, steal, do do immoral
things to try and get that because their
self-worth was tied up in that goal
rather than God is trying to work with
us with the process. It's really
interesting.
>> Yeah, that is really interesting because
like you said, that's what you see here
with with the Tower of Babel is that
same
>> pyramid structure. It's kind of the
natural social structure of selfishness.
Yeah, there's a view on top. Rest rest
of
>> is the Tower of Babel just just curious,
maybe Keith or you Cameron know this,
but is that really what it used to look
like? Do we have evidence for that or is
this just like in our artwork over the
years? This is how we have made it to
look.
>> Good question. I have no idea. I think
if I remember right, um archaeological
evidence would suggest it's some kind of
zigurat.
>> Oh, right. Um, but you know, the shape
and how many levels and all that I think
is
>> Yeah, sure. I mean, we know that they
were wanting to build a huge tower,
which necessitates a base that's wider
than the top. And so you get that
>> um and they're trying to reach up to
heaven which is why we have this
>> you'll notice that the um Adam and Eve
even though they were on earth they're
in the clouds
>> because in this illustration the clouds
yeah were kind of a motif to represent
the perfect you know perfection or
heavenly
>> in comparison with the earthly the human
powers. And so we kind of used the Satan
falling as lightning from heaven to also
signify the fall of humanity.
>> Yes. And it's then the same power here
is is striking down the tower of babel
and lighting the first sacrifice.
>> Yeah.
>> And so basically what it's presented
here is as soon as we fell from paradise
>> nice
>> we had these two paths. We either tried
to build our own way back to paradise
with our own power or we put our hope in
the true hope of Christ who would come
>> and truly be able to fix society. Do you
guys remember when we did something on
um Wreck-It Ralph?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And his building was up in the clouds.
Do you remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> And isn't that I mean what you just said
there is really interesting that um um
you know it's it's almost like the
clouds God used a cloud when he followed
around the Israelites, right? Oh yeah.
>> The cloud is a representation when we
when we draw heaven. What do we mostly
draw like? It's with clouds and stuff
like this. Right. So it's very heavenly
like.
>> And I never thought about that. The
Tower of Babel was like trying to get
back in the clouds but from the human
built upon a human foundation.
>> That's interesting.
>> Yeah. And so that's what all of these
empires are, you know, afterwards the
same thing. Human attempt to restore
utopia.
>> Yeah.
>> And in instead they all turn into a dog
pile of people clawing their way to get
to the top.
>> And that's why Jesus said, "I am the
way, the truth, and the life. No man can
come to the father but by me." You know,
it's like he is the reason that we would
even go to heaven.
>> And and so you'll notice that
>> unlike the mounds, unlike the kingdoms
that are on these mounds that people
have to claw over each other to get to
the top, the cross is at sea level.
>> Yeah.
>> It's accessible to all people. There's
no competition.
>> And that's the only place where the
water is still enough. It's peaceful.
It's still enough to reflect the image
of heaven on earth in God's remnant
people.
>> Mhm. What's the little cross behind it?
And is that like a tabernacle? Oh,
that's Jesus birth.
>> That's cool.
>> Yeah. Nativity.
>> On this dimension, we kind of have
Christ's life with his birth, baptism.
>> Oh, and his death.
>> And a sword is representing a war. And I
like how you put the tail like aiming
towards the cross like like I'm going to
take you out, you know?
>> And it's it's Rome, right? It's the tail
of Rome.
>> So, it's iron. Yeah.
>> Oh, it's iron. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So, yeah.
>> It represents Herod trying to take out
baby Jesus. prophetically the beast
waiting for the woman to give birth to
the seed.
>> Yeah. Was that Revelation 17 or 12?
>> Revelation 12, I think.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I always found that interesting
that, you know, the the wise men went to
go ask Herod where the baby was going to
be born and the Messiah and everything.
They answered him.
>> They It wasn't They weren't ignorant.
They went, "Oh, it's in Bethlehem and
it's during this time." That's why he
went and killed all the babies.
>> So, it's like you knew when he was going
to come
>> and I can't believe they denied it
anyway, you know?
>> Right. 100%. Yeah. And um and of course
Christ's life happened during the
beginning of the Roman Empire. And so
the tale there starts.
>> So the flow of this is you're starting
in the top left kind of swooping down.
>> Yes.
>> To the bottom where the center is.
>> Mhm.
>> And then where do we go?
>> So from there we go through of course
Rome here. And you'll notice each of the
mountains have the architectural
elements. So there's the coliseum.
>> Um
>> I like that it's broken.
>> Yeah. This was supposed to be the
sanctuary that the beast was trampling
underfoot.
>> But we weren't sure how to make it clear
that all these pieces of rubble, you
know, is a sanctuary.
>> That
>> um
>> anyway, just some elements we tried to
work in there that didn't come out.
>> I like the imagery of this. I don't know
maybe you were thinking about this, but
like because it it's so typical of the
world system doesn't care who they step
on.
>> Yeah.
>> Like you're not you're not looking at
Jesus crushing people and like you know
ready to eat them and stuff like that.
That's what they do to their own kind.
Mhm.
>> Right. Yeah. 100%. Um and so then you
have the the little horn that plucks out
the three. Uh and then we come here to
the beast of Revelation 17 with the
woman. And so basically here there are
these two women, these two churches.
One of them is the bride of Christ
waiting for her groom Christ coming in
the cloud. So we have the second coming
of Christ here. She's faithful to
Christ. This other woman is a church
that is cheating on Christ with the
beast.
>> She's a harlot,
>> right?
>> And and that's what why it says all n
she has made all nations drink of the
wine of the wrath of her fornication.
>> Her fornication is that unholy union
between church and state power. It's a
religion that believes it can fix
society if it controls everything
enough.
>> Mhm. rather than a religion, a church
that relies on the transforming power of
Christ
>> to change society.
>> So what is the wine here? I mean, I know
we've studied it, but just wanted if you
can explain it for the viewers.
>> Yeah. So wine in the Bible represents
doctrine essentially. And
>> what you find with the wine of Babylon
is it's essentially the the mentality of
Babylon. And that's why it talks about
people being drunk with the wine of
Babylon because people being intoxicated
with this mentality of control and
selfishness and force and coercion.
>> Um, which is then why it goes into the
water and it's all these people drunk
with that mentality. That's so it's so
interesting to see because one the Bible
>> the Bible explains that a woman is is
symbolic of of or bride is symbolic of
God's church, right? So you have the
pure woman, the pure bride on the right
>> and then the the harlot on the left
where you know when you study Bible
prophecy it's like a church state
combination but intoxicated with this
wine, this doctrine. And then if you can
go down a little bit to see the ocean,
you know, the Bible's very clear that
that waters means like populated areas,
like it's people, right?
>> Um and so yeah, like she pours her wine
into where the majority
>> of the people are. And who are these
people? Well, obviously um you know, if
you if you see uh study Bible prophecy,
yeah, it's like it's people of all kinds
of religion, the world and stuff like
that, but it's also a lot of Christians,
>> right? And so, so basically it's
Christians who follow this this beast
power or this woman that woman riding
the beast um and this woman representing
a church and then like you said Scotty
you just have to type into Google church
purple and scarlet or purple and red. I
mean it's very obvious once you actually
understand just just put the pieces
together
>> when you're in um the water also you're
tossed about with the waves. So, I
thought that that was a really neat
comment. I hadn't thought of that
before. And and it's like, yeah, you're
not calm, so you're just kind of getting
tossed to and fro with wherever things
are pushing you.
>> There's no peace.
>> Yeah, there's no peace. There's no calm,
though. Like, sea of glass. Oh, man.
It's opposite of sea of glass. See,
here's what I love about the Bible. It's
just it's just on and on and on. Yeah.
You see so much and and you know, to be
scared of this and then all of a sudden
like you start getting some
understanding. I think it it makes you
hungrier
>> like when you start to go, "Oh, wow.
That makes sense. Oh, wow." And then you
just kind of go,
>> "Absolutely."
>> So then these these streams of people
>> Yeah.
>> that are coming, it looks like from out
of the water
>> are these people that are coming out of
that system,
>> right?
>> And they're coming towards the cross.
>> Come out of her from Babylon, my people.
>> They're going that way.
>> Right. So just the other layer on top of
that is Christ said, "If I be lifted up,
>> Yes.
>> it will draw all men unto me." Yeah.
>> And so the cross is obviously the
ultimate expression of God's love being
lifted up.
>> But us, right, the remnant, these people
who are reflecting the character of God
to the world, it's also this lifting up
of Christ in our lives. And so both the
cross and the light of God's character
reflected in his people is drawing all
people unto him. Yes. And so these are
these people, like you said, they're
going against the flow of the rest of
the world being drawn to the light of
God's character.
>> I was going to mention too, this is in
the Old Testament, one in one of Moses'
books where it talks about there's a
there's a there's a drink offering
that's being poured out.
>> Keith, correct me if I'm wrong, but my
understanding is that's that's like
representing Jesus being poured out for
us, right? Like dying on the cross. So
now you have like this one cup and this
other cup and this cup is being poured
out and it's like this false doctrine
and like almost like a technically it's
understanding that it's a it's a woman
symbol of a church a false woman pouring
this out. It's a a doctrine a false
doctrine of a church being poured out a
false gospel and then you have Jesus
symbolized by the drink offering being
poured out on this side and he is the
true gospel. Right? So you have like
opposites there as well.
>> Yeah. Satan's just counterfeiting it.
>> And I I think that's actually a really
interesting point because we talk about
the wine as the spirit of Babylon.
>> The characteristic of the kingdom of
heaven is the spirit of Christ.
>> Yeah.
>> And of course spirits are referred to
actually refer to liquor which is
interesting because you have this wine
right the spirit of Babylon. Uh, and you
can become intoxicated with that or you
can be transformed by the spirit of
Christ.
>> It's almost like it's almost like an
energy drink, right? Death. Death in a
can, you know? What in the world?
>> Yeah. Maybe if they made the the wine of
the Babylon to a serious energy
drink. It would be like
>> Don't be giving anybody those ideas. I
like how you got the dragon's head in
the clouds here. Is that is it or is
that his tail?
>> Yeah, the dragon is um you first saw it
up here.
>> It's its tail. Yeah.
>> It wraps around here.
>> Yeah.
>> Around here.
>> It's in the water trying to keep block
people's way to Christ.
>> Exactly. He's trying to mimic and and
Yeah. get in between.
>> Mhm.
>> And then it goes all the way up to here
where you have the head
>> which is aimed at the woman.
>> Focused on this last moment of Earth's
history. He knows his time is short
>> and he's focused on his pride, his
jewel, his woman right there.
>> Mhm.
>> What What about the lamblike beast here?
>> Oh, yeah. So, the lamblike beast, yes,
is in this weird position because we
were playing with the idea that the the
stone, God's kingdom that comes and
destroys all of these broken, oppressive
human kingdoms, it's like the shock wave
blowing them back. So,
>> yeah. Sacrifice.
>> Um Yeah, exactly. And and this, of
course, we have it says it's a has two
horns like a lamb, but it speaks like a
dragon.
>> That's right.
>> Can you zoom into his head for a second?
>> So, you gave it a dragon's tongue.
>> Exactly. and
>> and his eyes are of the eyes of a
dragon.
>> Right. Right.
>> And and of course those are very
intentional symbols, you know, that John
was familiar with.
>> The lamb representation of Christ. Yeah.
That too.
>> Yeah.
>> The lamb represents Christ. The dragon
represents Satan, but it says it
>> looks like Christ, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But it actually speaks and it acts
civily as a dragon, as Satan. Uh, and so
it really uh perfectly kind of
represents America because we know it's
this this nation that it claims and
professes to be like Christ, a Christian
nation, but it's done all sorts of
coercive dragon-like things.
>> Uh, and it's doing more of that.
>> We started because of religious pro
persecution.
>> So, they fled that to have an ability to
worship how you feel God's called you to
worship. the freedom to have that
religion. And it's weird to be in the
day that we're watching this thing get
linked back together.
>> Yeah.
>> Absolutely.
>> You know, it's like we've been hearing
about this for years and I mean 200
years it's come full circle from running
away from it and saying we want nothing
to do with that system that's controlled
everybody to be the system that's now
controlling everybody. And
>> so, you know, I think that's I actually
like that you got a lamb in here that
has these like dragon parts because I
mean that's really truly what what we we
we are a, you know, supposedly Christian
nation, but honestly, how Christian
really is that Christian?
>> You know, when you can look behind a
curtain and you start seeing prophecy
unfold, it's like, oh boy,
>> if you just say, I believe in God, and
that's as far as you take it. And and I
mean, Satan believes in God, he's not
going to be saved. So, you know, it's
like the character is what I believe
this is all about. And and you haven't
brought up the um the mark of the beast
>> and um you know, give us a little
breakdown of that because it I there's
some comments I want to make about that.
>> Yeah. Um so, we don't have the mark
specifically overtly here. I mean, we
have obviously we have the beast and we
have the wine of the beast, which is the
mentality of the beast. Um I I think
mainly the the kind of narrative we were
choosing of like what goes in here and
what what doesn't was specifically uh
had to do with essentially kingdoms,
right? So we have the kingdom of heaven,
kingdom of of man, all these different
kingdoms and then the kingdom of God
comes destroys the kingdoms of man and
restores utopia again. So but yeah, go
ahead with the the mark of the beast.
I've heard um um I don't even remember
where I heard this from, but years ago
um you know mark the beast 666 that's on
the forehead, right? It's on the
forehead because what's on your
forehead? That's where you make your
choices. It's the moral reasoning powers
of you. If you cut your frontal lobe
off, you will be a different person.
>> Be like a beast basically.
>> Basically and and people that you know
go study Phineas Gage, right? Rod goes
through it and changed the guy's
personality. Um, but then you know
people kind of hyperfocus on that and
then they don't focus on the seal of
God.
>> And it's like the seal of God is God
saying these people have my character
and I'm and I'm and I it's like you've
completed the package. You know, we seal
things when we're done with it, right?
When it comes off the factory line or
whatever like that and it's like
finished product, it gets sealed.
>> And uh somebody somebody mentioned um
the 666
>> is man's number.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Number of a man. That's what the
Bible says, right? 777 is God's. And
it's almost like you have God the
Father, God the Son, and God the Holy
Spirit on your mind. Or you have the
three false prophets on your mind.
>> You mean false prophet and
>> the dragon and you know the 666 is like
God's not on your forehead. I am or you
are. Which is essentially the same as
Satan being on there.
>> Yeah.
>> It's interesting too as we like you're
saying, we hyperfocus on don't get the
mark. Don't get the mark. Don't get the
mark. Ultimately, what the Bible is
teaching us though at the end of time,
everybody gets marked.
>> Everybody. Yeah.
>> Everybody. Yeah. You're going to get a
mark.
>> And it's not for us necessarily. Like,
it's not it's not a tattoo because we
don't we're not going to know, right?
It's for the rest of the universe for
God to make choices about what's
happening here so that the rest of them
can see the the the great controversy
played out and they know exactly which
side people are on. And you see them act
that way.
>> Yeah. I just want to drop in here that
we do have a video on our channel about
what is the mark and the video also
includes what is the seal of God. So you
get both perspectives um video on the
antichrist as well according to
scripture it's very clear.
>> You can't go wrong with it once you
study scripture.
>> Yeah it's about worship.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Um it was about
worship in Daniel 3. Um,
another thing that's interesting because
we were thinking about this last night
actually, my family and I. Um, worship
was the issue with the slaves in Egypt,
right? Let us worship.
>> Very true.
>> Um, it was the issue with with Esther.
You had almost all the people wiped out
because this guy was mad because he
wouldn't worship him as a god.
>> Very true.
>> Um, and then same thing that you have in
Daniel 3 and then you have it and final,
you know, bow down. That's right. Cain
and from the very Adam and Eve as well.
Who do you worship?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. You know, you know, in the Cain
and Abel um story, it's really really
kind of interesting. Um you know, Cain
coming with something that that he is
outside of him to fix this problem.
>> And Cain came with something that's like
I can fix this problem in my own way.
Which speaks to your point of the Tower
of Babel saying we can build this thing
back up to a heaven state and we don't
need you.
>> Right.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. our foundation is the earth. And
Jesus when he was here, he's like, "My
my I'm not from here. I'm from there."
You know,
>> right?
>> He was also repeating his mother's
mistake, if you will.
>> And and that's really essentially what
it boils down to, the end of time. In
Genesis,
you have God saying, "This is what I
require,
right?"
>> And then man chooses to do otherwise.
Cain and Abel, same thing.
it. God says this is what I require
and then Cain is choosing to do it
differently because he says that it
doesn't matter.
>> Well, God says, you know, it's flexible.
I can interpret it the way I want. The
end of time, same thing. God says this
is what I require. And man saying, it's
really not that important. I can
interpret that the way I want.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> I love this. So, of course, what we have
at the end here is essentially there's
these two sides. And it's not two sides
drawn down some denominational line.
It's
>> two different mentalities.
>> It doesn't matter what denomination
you're part of. You're not automatically
immune to the wine of Babylon.
>> Um, you can you could still have that
mentality. And so you can be part of
either
what what do you use?
What do you rely on to fix the society
to to um solve anything really your your
own salvation? Are you using your own
power? It's essentially righteousness by
works
>> versus righteousness by faith.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah. And you either are saying if I
control everything enough it can be it
can be perfect or it's the power of
Christ and and that is what we rely on.
And and I think it's much more appealing
to think oh we can change society with
using you know political power
>> forome
>> because I don't have to actually care
about people. I don't have to labor for
people. I don't have to go out there and
and care about people. We can just make
laws that clean up the parts of society
I don't like.
>> And I can continue living in my nice
picket fence neighborhood.
>> But the spirit of Christ and the
mentality, the the approach of the
kingdom of heaven requires so much more
commitment.
>> It requires going out and living like
Christ and being the hands and feet of
Christ and letting others see him
through you.
>> That takes a lot more work. That's a
that's a lot more difficult. Yeah,
>> you know, we finally have the second
coming where the the groom meets, you
know, the bride of Christ. Um, the
church is is, you know, returned to
Christ, but they've they've already
been, you know, wed. They've been she's
been faithful to Christ this whole time.
And then we have the kingdom of heaven
coming and striking and breaking down
all of these oppressive, broken systems,
>> giving way to the new earth. And we see
here Adam and Eve restored back. Amen.
from paradise to paradise.
>> Nice.
>> Amen.
>> So I think I think this is so be
beautifully portrayed and described
because like this really is the story of
love of God's love for mankind. And I
think this really unveils Revelation,
not making it seem like some, and
Daniel, I should say, not making it seem
like some scary story, which it could
sound like for some people or some
people are like, "Oh, I cannot figure
that out." When really, you can. And and
you're showing that.
>> You know, one thing that's interesting
about pieces of art like this is when
you start to teach children, you often
use pictures,
>> right? You show them an apple and you
sell them this is an apple, you know,
and they learn that way. They'll learn
how to read that way. The reading part,
you know, the the very technical part
comes later. The the imagery comes first
often times, not in every case, but
often times. And so what's nice about
something like this is you can take that
and you can take this this image and you
can show it to a child and tell them the
story
>> and they can understand in a very vivid
real way
>> through this through this picture and it
would make sense to them.
>> I think that's why God made this a
visual book
>> for that exact reason right there. He's
like look there's a language barrier
here. You all speak different languages
and stuff like this. Obviously, he he
caused that. But I'm going to make it in
something you don't even have to like
know what that is. If you seek, you will
find. If you look, here's the picture.
>> The the double-edged sword to that is
many times people write books and then
what happens? A lot of a lot of those
things get made into movies and people
would rather watch the movie than read
the book, right? It's it's like
appealing to that
>> visual nature of ours. Like we want to
see it come to life. It's it's like more
>> it seems more palatable way for us to
understand the story. So
>> not saying that's always right and I'm
not saying we shouldn't read because
when you read
>> you get a lot of detail that often times
isn't in the other. This is like a more
simplified version
>> but I like the other is it that can be a
first introduction.
>> Yeah, first introduction. So what you're
doing is wetting the the the pallet for
it and going oh wow you actually
understand this you know and then it's
like where did you get this from? And
then once you start digging the more
that you dig the more that you're just
like mind blown mind blown.
>> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Sizzle and you can retain that imagery
in your mind as you expand on the story.
>> And plus you know it's one picture right
here. You want to do a Bible study? You
need a picture.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm. Yeah. It's great.
>> Send it to your phone.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. So, can people
go to your website and just like see all
this stuff on there if they want to
explore
>> the the that explorer is was directly
online on our website. You go to
rebrandprophecy.art,
scroll down, full screen it, and you can
explore the entire 24 ft illustration.
>> Awesome. And your Kickstarter, when does
it start?
>> Um, probably sometime beginning of next
year.
>> Okay.
>> We're working on developing this um
getting it to the point that it can kind
of start funding development of the
show. Cool. Y
>> maybe when you get close to that, come
back. We'd love to like, you know, let
our audience know again.
>> That'd be awesome.
>> Cool. Well, how can people donate to
your project?
>> Um, just go to rebrandprophecy.org
or if if you just type in
rebrandprophecy online, it'll pop up.
And uh
>> yeah, that's that's the way.
>> Cool. I love it.
>> Thank you for stopping by.
>> Thank you guys. It was really fun
talking with you all.
>> Awesome. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
>> And drop a comments below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
>> Say that again. No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]